hey guys this is andrew for shaving
sensors.com so i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong on the option market
and i've just started guys to make some
youtube videos a few months ago
because i want to show you guys all the
different tools and techniques
that i use at work that work for me and
most importantly i want to show you how
to use it yourself
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and basically how to make money on
the markets you guys are in the right
place
so today i want to make an update on
tesla let's get into it
[Music]
so um i used to do a lot of videos on
tesla and
i basically you know i didn't do for at
least three weeks and i was telling you
guys that i see you know the momentum
shifting and becoming bearish and that
we're doing
uh the force wave of the larger degree
uh wave cycle
and that basically i see a correction
happening so and nothing uh you know
very exciting so that's why i was not
doing videos but right now we're coming
closer so this i did this counting one
month ago
and you know it's still valid we are
following exactly what i was saying
is that we are correcting when the false
wave and we are wondering basically when
this force wave is going to be done
so first let me go with you quickly
through this
counting so idiot wave theory is saying
that
moves up develop in five waves and moves
down develop in three waves abc
and the this theory is actually
a little game that consists of finding
the best counting that is fitting the
price action the best
in order to predict where we are in
terms of wave development and
where we might be heading so here
i do my one two three four five of the
larger degree cycle like this
one two three four five and i can
explain why
my five is not here but here at two
thousand guys but
okay this level is very approximative
it's not important right now what is
important is that we're correcting and
this is only for suede
and how i know that it's because in each
uh
impulse that i have here so an impulse
is like
actually a motive wave so for those who
want to understand more about all the
different patterns
so you can have impulse or diagonal you
can have a flat
triangle or zigzag for the corrective
patterns
you can just click on the description of
this video there is a link
that is gonna send you right away a free
video
where i explain everything guys about
this incredible method
and here what i wanted to show you is
that i'm
you know kind of convinced of
discounting because each impulse can be
subdivided
in one two three four five impulse as
well and this is telling me that my
counting is correct so here look one two
three four five
here one two three four five with the
third wave divided in one two three four
five and each time the third wave is the
biggest so this is telling me that this
counting
is probably correct so right now we're
doing the force and we're expecting a
fifth wave
to arrive i would say around mid-may so
now
let's dive deeper in what we're having
in this force wave all right so let me
get rid of this
the forward time frame is good and we
are wondering so a force wave is a
corrective pattern so guys
it is here we had a zigzag
this is a beautiful zigzag so here we
expect a flat because when you have a
zigzag in the second
corrective wave usually you have a flat
but it's not always you can have a
zigzag as well
so but most likely we're gonna have a
flat and something like this
all right this would be a flat so let's
see if we have something like this
this could be a flat as well so
basically i'm expecting guys the price
action to go slightly higher
uh before getting bearish again and here
where are my resistance level that are
going to tell me when
this price action might revert i have
here the 200 period moving average on
the forward stem frame which is
a very good indicator to use at 7 30.
so the biggest resistance is at 7 30 and
i expect we reach it
we get rejected and then only then guys
we're gonna have something like this
and when once we break this this is
going to be the end of the force wave
all right
so i expect tesla to do something like
this guys all right
and here i showed you guys that this
is a strong support
all right because i have the maximum of
my third wave that is here so
this is to me a very strong support and
this acted as support here and i expect
a flat correction so i don't expect the
c wave to be actually
deeper than the uh a wave and once
we finally finish this corrective
patterns which once again is going to be
around mid-may or even june you know
something like this
once we've we're done with that we can
finally
develop in the fifth wave and where the
fifth wave
might go this is given by fib extensions
you just measure the
previously wave you apply it to the
bottom of the force wave that is for now
500 520 something like this so let's see
if we go lower or not if we go over i'm
gonna adjust that but for now it's here
and you take the 1.618 so this is giving
me 2 000
as a target that we might see i don't
know maybe
uh end of 2021 so in six
nine months uh so this is very bullish
and
uh once again i explained to you guys
why i see a price action that bullish is
because i'm missing a fifth wave
so right now we're correcting uh the
force wave and we're gonna do the final
fifth wave before
probably a deeper correction so that's
it for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys